PROFESSOR: The fact is
that angular momentum is
an observable, and as such
it deserves attention.
There is an active way of
thinking of observables,
and we have not developed
it that much in this course.
But for example, with
a momentum operator
you've learned that the
momentum operator can give you
the differential operator.
It's a derivative, and
derivatives tell you how
to move, how a function varies.
So with the momentum
operator, for example,
you have the momentum
operator p hat,
which is h bar over i d dx.
And you could ask
the question of, OK,
so the momentum operator
moves or takes a derivative,
does the momentum
operator move a function?
Does it generate a translation?
And the answer is, yes.
That's another way of thinking
of the momentum operator
as a generator of translations.
But how does it do it?
This is a Hermitian operator,
and it takes a derivative.
It doesn't translate
the function.
But there is a universal
trick that if you exponentiate
i times a Hermitian
operator, you
get a new kind of operator
that actually, in this case,
moves things.
So we could think
of exponentiating
e to the i p hat, and
for purposes of units
I have to put a constant
with units of length,
and an h bar here.
And now you have the
exponential of an operator.
That's good.
That's a very
interesting operator,
and we can ask what
does it do when
you act on a wave function?
It's an operator.
And look, simplify by putting
what p is going to do.
P is h over i d dx.
So this is like a
d dx exponentiated
acting on psi of x.
And as an exponential,
it can be expanded
in a Taylor series with
this funny object there,
but it would be the
sum from n equals 0
to infinity 1 over
n factorial a d dx.
I will write it this
as normal derivatives,
because we just have a function
of x, a d dx to the n psi of x.
And you see that,
of course, this
is psi of x plus a d
psi dx plus 1 over 2
a squared, d second
psi dx squared.
But this is nothing else but
the Taylor series for this.
And there it is, the miracle.
The e to the i momentum
generated translation.
It really moves
the wave function.
So that in a sense
is a deeper way
of characterizing
the momentum operator
as a generator of translations.
With the angular
momentum operators,
we will have that they
generate rotations.
So I need a little bit
more mathematics here,
because I have to deal with
three dimensions, a vector,
and produce an exponential
that rotates the vector,
so that it gives you the wave
function at a rotated point.
But this will be the same story.
Angular momentum will
generate rotations
the same way as momentum
generates translations.
And there is yet another story
that when you will appreciate
the abstract properties
of angular momentum
that some of them
will appear today,
you will realize that in
addition of angular momentum
that represent rotations
of objects doing things,
there is another way of
having angular momentum.
And that's spin
angular momentum.
That mysterious property
of particles that have--
even though they
have 0 size, they
behave as if they were little
balls rotating and spinning.
That spin angular momentum
has no ordinary wave functions
associated to it, and
it's fractional sometimes.
And the study of angular
momentum inspired
by orbital angular
momentum associated
with normal rotations,
will lead us
to understand where spin
angular momentum comes about.
So it's a gigantic
interesting subject,
and we're beginning
with it today.
So it's really quantum
mechanics in three dimensions,
central potentials,
and angular momentum.
And let's begin by
mentioning that if we
are in three dimensions--
and many things
with it so far in
this course, we always
took the time to write
them in three dimensions.
So we wrote this, for
example, as a generalization
of the derivative form
of the momentum operator.
Meaning there is a Px,
which is h bar over i d dx,
Py h bar over i d dy, and
Pz equal h bar over i d dz.
And we had commutators within Px
and x, Py and y, and Pz and z.
There were always the same
commutators of the form
x Px equal i h bar.
Similar things here.
With this we wrote the three
dimensional Schrodinger
equation, which was minus h
squared over 2m, and instead
of p squared three
dimensional, he
would have a derivative if you
were doing in one dimension.
For three dimensions
you have the Laplacian.
And this time you
have a wave function
that depends on the
vector x plus v of r--
v of x.
Should I write r?
Let me write r vector.
V of r psi of r
equal e psi of r.
This is our time independent
Schrodinger equation.
This corresponds to
the energy eigenstate,
but in three dimensions.
So this is the equation
we wish to understand,
and our ability to
understand that equation
in a simple and nice way
rests on a simplification.
That is not always
true, but it's
true under so many
circumstances that it's worth
studying by itself.
And it's the case when you
have a central potential,
and by that we mean that
the potential is not
quite the vector function
of r, but is just a function
of the magnitude of r.
That's a little bit
funny way of writing it,
because I'm using
the same letter v,
but I hope there's no confusion.
I mean that the potential just
depends on the value of r.
So what this means physically
is that over concentric spheres,
the potential is constant.
All over the surface of
spheres of constant radius,
the potential is
constant, because it only
depends on the radius.
And this potential is there
for a spherically symmetric.
You can rotate the
world, and the potential
still looks the same, because
rotations don't change
the magnitude of vectors.
If you have a vector of
some length, you rotate it,
it's the same length,
and therefore you
remain on this sphere.
So the central potential
are spherically symmetric.
By that we mean they're
invariant under rotations.
So this is the reason
why angular momentum will
play an important role, because
precisely the angular momentum
operators, in the fashion
we discussed a minute ago,
generate rotation.
So they will have
a nice interplay,
to be developed in the following
lectures, with the Hamiltonian.
So at this moment we
have a central potential,
and let's assume
that's the case.
And we need to
understand a little more
of this differential equation.
So let me write the formula for
the Laplacian of a function.
It has a radial contribution.
You know it's second
order derivatives.
And it has a radial part,
and an angular part.
The units are 1
over length squared.
So you need, if you have an
angular part, all over here
is going to be
angular, you still
need the 1 over on r squared
here for the units to work out.
So here it is, it's
slightly complicated.
d d theta sine
theta d d theta of--
well, put the psi, plus 1
over sine squared theta,
d second d phi squared
all acting on psi.
It's a complicated
operator, and here
is some radial
derivatives, and here there
are some angular derivatives.
So you see, today's lecture
will have many steps,
and you have to keep track
of where we're going.
And what we're going
to do is, build up
a structure that
allows us pretty much
to forget about all this thing.
That's our goal.
And angular momentum will
play a role in doing this.
So there are in fact two
things I want to justify,
two facts to be justified.
So I will erase this.
The first fact is the relation
between this differential
operator and angular momentum.
So two facts to justify.
The first is that minus h
squared 1 over sine theta
d d theta sine theta d d theta
plus 1 over sine squared theta
d second d phi squared.
This whole thing can be viewed
as the differential operator
version of angular momentum.
Remember, d dx was a
differential operator version
of momentum.
So maybe this has to do with
angular momentum, and indeed
this whole thing, remember,
units of angular momentum
is h bar.
Angular momentum is
length times momentum.
And from the
certainty principle,
you know that x times
p has units of h bar.
So angular momentum
has units of h bar.
So there's h bar squared here.
So this must be angular
momentum squared.
In fact, if you
think about that,
angular momentum is x times p.
So x times a derivative.
So it's a first order
differential operator,
but this is a second order one.
So this could not be
just angular momentum.
Anyway, angular
momentum is a vector.
So this will turn
out to be, and we
will want to justify L squared.
The quantum version of the
angular momentum operator
squared.
And the other thing I want
to justify if I write--
call this equation one.
So this is fact
one, and fact two,
is that equation one
is relevant, when--
let me wait a second
to complete this.
This equation is an
equation for a particle
moving in a potential,
a spherically
symmetric potential.
It turns out that is
relevant under more
general circumstances.
If you have two particles
whose potential energy--
if you have two
particles you have
a potential energy between them,
maybe it's a electromagnetic--
if the potential
energy just depends
on the distance
that separates them,
this two body problem can
be reduced to a one body
problem of this form.
This is a fairly non-trivial
fact, and an absolutely
interesting one.
Because if you want to really
solve the hydrogen atom,
you have an electron
and a proton.
Now it turns out that the proton
is almost 2,000 times heavier
than the electron.
And therefore, you
could almost think
that the proton
creates a potential
in which the electron moves.
But similar analysis is valid
for neuron orbiting a nucleus.
And in that case, the neuron is
still lighter than the proton,
but not that much lighter.
Or maybe for a quark and an
anti-quark orbiting each other.
Or an electron and a
positron orbiting each other,
and this would be
valid and useful.
So we need to somehow
explain that as well.
If you really want to
understand what's going on,
is that equation
one is relevant when
we have a two body problem
with a potential function
v of x1 x2.
The potential energy
given that configuration,
x1 and x2 of the first
and second particle,
is a function of
the separation only.
The absolute value or the length
of the vector, it's 1 minus x2.
This far we'll
get through today.
This will be next lecture still.